so right here we have a four-sided
figure or a quadrilateral where two of
the sides are parallel to each other and
so this by definition is a trapezoid
trapezoid and what we want to do is
given the dimensions that they've given
us what is the area of this trapezoid so
let's just think through it so what
would we get if we multiplied this base
this long base six times the height
three so what do we get if we multiply
six times three
well that would be the area of a
rectangle that is six six units wide and
three units high so that would give us
the area of a figure that looked like
let me do it in this pink color the area
of a figure that looked like this would
be six times three so it would give us
this entire this entire area right over
there now the trapezoid is clearly less
than that but let's just let's just go
with the thought experiment now what
would happen if we went with two times
three two times three well now we'd be
finding the area of a rectangle that has
a width of two and a height of three so
you could imagine that being this
rectangle right over here so that is
this rectangle right over here so that's
the two times three rectangle now it
looks like the area of the trapezoid
should be in between these two numbers
maybe it should be exactly halfway in
between because when you look at the
area difference between the two
rectangles and let me color that in let
me color so this is the area difference
on the left hand side and this is the
area difference the area difference on
the right hand side if we focus on the
trapezoid you see that it reclaims if we
start with the yellow the smaller
rectangle it reclaims half of the area
half of the difference between the
smaller rectangle of the larger one on
the left hand side it gets exactly half
of it on the left hand side and it gets
half the difference between the smaller
and the larger on the right hand side so
it completely makes
sense completely makes sense that the
area of the trapezoid D this entire area
right over here should really just be
the average it should exactly be halfway
between the areas of the smaller
rectangle and the larger rectangle so
let's take the average of those two
numbers it's going to be 6 times 3 plus
2 times 3 all of that over all of that
over 2 so when you think about an area
of a trapezoid you look at you look at
the two bases the the long base and the
short base take the area of each of or
multiply each of those times the height
and then you could take the average of
them or you could also think of it as
this is the same thing as 6 plus 2 and
I'm just factoring out a 3 here 6 plus 2
6 plus 2 times 3 times 3 and then all of
that all of that over 2 which is the
same thing as and I'm just writing it in
different ways these are all different
ways to think about it 6 plus 2 over 2
over 2 and then that times 3 so you
could view it as the average of the
smaller and larger rectangle so you
multiply each of the bases times the
height and then take the average you
could view it as well let's just add up
the two base lengths multiply that times
the height and then divide by 2 or you
could say let's take the average of the
2 base lengths and multiply that by 3
and that gives you another interesting
way to think about it if you take the
average of these two lengths 6 plus 2
over 2 is 4 so that would be that would
be a width that looks something like we
just orange a width of 4 would look
something like this with a 4 would look
something like that and you're
multiplying that times a height well
that would be a rectangle like this that
is exactly halfway in between the areas
of the small and the large rectangle so
these are all equivalent statements now
let's actually just calculate it so we
can do any of these 6 times 3 is 18 this
is 18 plus 6
/ - that is 24 / 2 or 12 you could also
do it this way 6 plus 2 is 8 times 3 is
24 divided by 2 is 12 6 plus 2 divided
by 2 is 4 times 3 is 12
either way the area of this trapezoid is
12 square units